Thì em thấy mở lớp Viva sẽ lại từ đầu cho học sinh 2 gân mời và em mất gốc chỉ từ lắm mời của tham gia đe xong mà
Sao ngồi thương ra nát đếm nhỏ
Đây là một lớp dây lại từ đầu, cái thương mời mùa và lấy gốc lại cho các bạn khi mà các bạn đã mại trời trong xưa dị hẹn vào tôi
Rất nhiều học sinh 2 gân mời đến thời điểm hiện tại, hết 2 phần 3 cái hẹn này rồi
Mình chưa chỉ như xưa vắt sở một chứ nào, mình sẽ bị lấy mùa, lấy là một trong nhiều sai lập lần nhất mà các bạn có thể khảm
Trong truyền hợp lắm mời mùa đây
Vình lấy mùa nó khó hơn và nặng nô vình lấy mời rất dất nhiều
Dù rất nhiều mà dạc bài, để các công tục tình gó ăn, nó có hẹn quá
Chắc chắn là nếu như các bạn không xuất ngay cho hẹn này
Thì nào nó mùa rất khó là cái theo kiếp cái màa sạm trên lớp của các bạn
Ở býu lại cho nên ngay không ngay của nó một tình phu dây cho các bạn
Đó là bạn phải khá bị bởi chúng bởi, cái này nó ngủ đó khoảng 2,8 hút thôi
Cái này chính thức xanh 3, lớp 3, đây là một lớp dây lại từ đầu cho chỉ vình lấy mùa mùa mùa mùa mùa hành dành cho các bạn
Đi nó hả bí lấy lớp vào nơi trường hả bí thôi
Nếu hả bởi lất ngay chính thức thăng cường thêm
Vình thường mình thật của các lớp vi vui thay sẽ xây vào mùa nó sáng thức tư của thức bài hả bòi hả bòi
Nhưng mà bòi lất ngay thì nó sẽ có 1 liệt nữa
Nó nó lình vay lại từ đầu vào mùa nó sáng thức bài hả bòi
Tức là bủ xuân thêm cho các bạn bùi hả bữa tổng gần, bắt đầu lên
Mà bổn của gần để cho các chiếm linh kiện thức
Lên trống khoảng nhập của tất cả các bạn trong lớp
Công như là hả bệnh hả bệnh đầu cho chỉ có lý lấy mùa
Khi bệnh hả hả bòa nhạc
Và có chỉ còn mùa ngay đó thôi là tây chỉ thức khai sáng
Lớp bí bài hả bệnh đầu cho chỉ có lý lấy mùa rang cho 2 gâm hơi thôi
Thông tin như là phía cực bị tốt, vánh trong mạng
Mến thơ giềm phía tài
Công hả bệnh hả bệnh đầu, là nó hả bếnh hả bệnh đầu
Tháng ra bệnh bệnh mùa tài nhạc